everyone I'm Dave joined by will and
even curious about the new battlefield
stuff I have yeah luckily for you I on
Wednesday I was behind closed doors that
reveal and there was there was a load of
information that they didn't share in
the world wide reveal stream which was
baffling but now you've got your good
pal Dave to come and deliver all that
information to you lucky ways for the
people at home so the first thing that I
wanted to get wanted to touch on is a
lot of people are saying that they don't
look like soldiers that's because
customization is a huge thing in the
game now yes a huge part of it no yeah
you you can create a soldier and you can
create a company and that company could
have its own weapons have its own
vehicles have its own combatants so you
can completely customize the way your
character looks and that will carry
through through the game and other
people will see that the weapons that
you have can all be customized as well
and for the most part the customizations
are just cosmetic then that will carry
on to the vehicles the vehicles can have
the skins that you like they learn they
can be customized both in the way that
they look and the way that they play so
you can you can take your tiger tank and
give it extra armor but then the armor
will make it slower okay but then you
could take another tiger tank and give
it better engines you can really make
things play the way you want them to
play in which i think is a really good
direction beyond just like red dot
attachments so you have to buy those or
how do you get them so one thing I was
like this is really cool but is it too
good to be true they said that there's
no premium pass at all no premium pass
you won't pay for like any new maps
nothing the only thing you pay for is
cosmetics and they said further down the
line they'll be like a catch-up mechanic
so the minute it's just the cosmetics
but they can also be earned anyway the
way that they're introduced in your
content now is they're tides of war
there's their live service they're Corps
that features new maps new Mo's new
weapons the lock but one thing that I
found really interesting is because
there's a there's a new emphasis on
squad mechanics which we'll touch on in
a little while but because of that
that's influenced the way that they're
delivering this content like I was
saying to you imagine if we were playing
and I bought the new expansion pack when
it's play with you but you you hadn't
enough money to buy the expansion pack
my squad would be split yeah now because
they want to keep the squad together
they're not charging you for expansions
oh that's awesome so you know anytime
anything comes out we can we can just
play together and I was like I heard
that I was like yeah but I know I know
the couch so they're going after games
like overwatch way you get all the maps
for free but if it's like cosmetic you
might want to spend a bit of money yeah
anything which is I mean everyone's ever
knows what EA did with battlefront yeah
and I mean even previously in
battlefield games they had expansion
packs I've always been like really so
this is a fan piece that people are
gonna love this yeah like I definitely
hope so if they implement it well and
it's fair like great and there's so many
things to customize like I was just
saying that they're gonna probably make
that dollar back and keep their game
supported just through people buying
cool skins and honestly I'm the type of
guy that if you're respecting me as a
player and respecting my time and my
money and giving me content then I will
support you and speaking of looking good
players are actually gonna be able to
influence the way the battlefield looks
and plays now they also they've
introduced a fortification system now in
battlefield one everyone had a gas mask
in battlefield 5 everyone has a
fortification tool and with this tool
you can build things like sandbags
barbed wire dragon's teeth and those are
the big concrete things and stop tanks
oh cool the engineer however will have
more things to build more options to
build and they will build them faster
he's more efficient with it but the idea
is is that you can attack an objective
like attack a flag in conquest take it
with your squad and then it's built so
that if you're playing well with your
squad you
have time to fortify this area before
the counter-attack you can start
throwing up sandbags the engineer can
build a machine gun placement you can
dig a trench and then all of a sudden
you've got this this fortress that you
can hold from the counter-attack and
that works as well with with buildings
if you shell a building and its walls
are blowing out and it's windows are
being destroyed it's got no roof left
you can take that building start
shucking up sandbags chuck a machine gun
emplacement make a make like a murder
hole if your machine gunner to sit and
then that's your strong point and I
think that's gonna add so much to like
the the tactical thought of of
battlefields stationary weapons like
flak cannons and AAA you can just hook
them to the back of a half-track and
drive them so that's now one thing I
didn't expect them to do is you know if
I if I'm in a Sherman tank I'm driving
away I can attach like a flak ata
anti-aircraft gun to the back of it and
you can sit in it while I'm driving so
like all the planes that were murder
tanks you can just be towing you about
socialism out of the sky and I that's
like one of the things that I'm so
excited to play with and see how the
community reacts with because it's just
gonna all the flags that you used to
hate defending in previous games that or
that were ones that were always
contested if you work well with your
squad you can just completely just just
create this place of fortress and if
you're depth to it it's just gonna be
like enemies just gonna be thrown Eve
it's gonna be so cool to build little
defenses
so you mentioned attrition so what's
that yeah that's like it's a it's a new
feature in battlefield now the idea is
that the term that was used was that you
spawn capable but you're not gonna have
everything you need so when you spawn
into the battlefield you might have a
few magazines or one grenade you don't
have you one be like previous
battlefields where you can just self
sustained for a long time things like
your health or auto regen to 100 anymore
if you're wounded then and you take
cover you'll read you a little bit but
the only way to regenerate your health
would be to get a medic or two to get a
resupply station the whole fully stopped
thing is meant to kind of turn it on its
head the whole spawn like throw yourself
and objective
I not really be punished for it and then
just get back into the fight I can see
that encouraging people to instead of
just jumping in and being a lone wolf
actually thinking about how can I work
with my team and how can I contribute to
this battle rather than just playing for
themselves yeah if you you will get
spawned into a team by default now
there's the there's that hasn't been
this much emphasis on squad play in a
long time I'm really excited about that
if you're the squad leader they're not
more valuable because they can call in
reinforcements so I think they were
called basically the squad leader earns
enough points by giving objectives
sticking with their team getting kills
giving orders then they'll they'll earn
these points they can call in things
like a v1 rocket like a smoke garages
and unique squad vehicles like it was
like the Churchill crocodile flame
through a tank that sounds amazing see
all your all your all your squad can
just pile into this tank and then you
which is then customized because it's
part of your company so it's got your
like squad level livery on it it's got
your squad ornaments on it started going
into trench so this massive flamethrower
tank with the D emphasis on squad play
things like revive trains have gone so
you know in battlefield if you're a
medic you could just rub your defibs
together and just shock the air someone
everything now has a physical animation
or requires physical interaction so when
you pick up a med kit you have to push a
button get the med kit if you want to
pick up ammo you push a button get the
ammo if you're a medic you you if you
need if you wanna save someone you start
this animation which and if I was
picking you up on the battlefield I
would see how your character was
customized you would see me as my medic
I'd have to start this animation instead
of just syringe in the air get you get
you back up and get you back on the
field you can also drag your squad mates
now so if you're a medic and people are
shooting down an alleyway as like yeah I
might be able to save you but there's
bullets coming at me so grab them and
just pull them into cover so when
they're safe you can then you know apply
first aid but another really interesting
thing there's so much about so excited
about damn
for men squads they they'll be able to
revive each other there's thing called a
buddy revive right they take way longer
and they don't recover you to full
health so the medics are so hugely
important but if I was a support player
and you're a sniper or if I was poor
pair and you're a medic and I'm the last
guy it could be really important for me
to use the buddy revive which is slower
to get you back on your feet because
you're the medic but then when you're
back on your feet you can help me get
anyone else back to full house see right
and it's it's another way that makes it
more important to wipe squads but it
also emphasizes the medic role it
emphasizes the reason to stick with your
team to stay as that cohesive unit
because even if you if you're not medic
you can still help each other out so it
sounds like there's a lot more to think
about in terms of your role in that
squad and also the risks of your actions
do you heal someone or do you just leave
them to die because it's better off for
the team yeah but again with the
immersion spying is different like way
different what spotting so you know how
in previous Battlefield games you'd like
on keyboard think it's cue that you hit
come over ISM on console but if you're
aiming at someone it puts an icon above
the head and shows on the only map and
then your team can see all right okay
that in battlefield one especially
people would just like lean our cover
tap spot blow up their their HUD with
icons and shoot with the icons they were
calling them Doritos because they are
little little bread triangles and there
start shooting at those and people who
are using mortars just wait for an area
to just fill up with with red dots and
Isis and they haven't said how spotting
is going to work now but they saying
they said they want people to stop
staring it there at their head at the UI
and start looking at the world cuz Evan
said how spotting is going to work
exactly but there's things like if if
someone's running through grass or
crawling through grass or moving through
shrubbery that moves around them now
you'll be able to see that so if I'm a
sniper or a machine gunner and I start
seeing like these Reed's moving I should
like start mowing your down so you need
to look at the world more you need to
take it in instead of just being like
looking for dots or
during your home which obviously plays a
lot into the immersion and battlefield
as always then a great job of immersion
but it's it looks like they're
completely dialing that up that's cool
there's nothing sadder than they're
making this incredible world and then
you're only looking at the icons on top
of it like it's good to know that you're
gonna be able to appreciate the world a
bit more yeah
it's I'm crazy excited like I'd love to
just keep gushing over all the stuff
excited for but I know the American team
have gone into like a huge amount of
detail when it comes to that so if you
want more detail despite me waffling on
then go check that video out but I've
not been this excited by a battlefield
game in years do it side as well like it
looks really good and I'm not normally
about that guy so hyped for it I'm gonna
get my squad together with our badass
ladies get some cricket bats and start
caving some heads in sick if you get
good you okay do my best anyway we're
gonna be checking out more battlefield 5
at EA play so if you want to hear more
details about battlefield Africa we've
had some hands on make sure you
subscribe like the video if you enjoyed
you can follow me on twitter i'm at
regular dave and the quiff is dead and
if you've got any thoughts you want to
share make sure to leave them in the
comment section below
until next time thanks for watching and
I'll see ya
[Music]